I haven't said anything about what
information or skills you should use to
solve these so that's kind of up to you
part of what is in five point three
maths it's not just having the skills
but actually determining when you should
use one technique over not okay or when
one will work and with another would so
what typically use for the first one
Samuel very good we're using the sample
because you can see the information that
you've got pays up an angle with a side
and an angle with a side right two
angles one side and that's the left over
so what should I write is my first wine
before I start actually solving the
paper any takers
okay so I'm good X that's when I want to
solve right the side rule has this pair
of fractions right so X over sine 61
it's not you angle
don't forget degrees by the way I'll
just make a note there I've said this a
few times but I haven't really explained
it very much I've sent degrees because
degrees are one way to measure angles
when you progressed into to you you will
learn another substantially different
way of measuring angles so that's why
represents a 61 degrees and not just
sixty one because then this sixty one
other things and you'll learn about the
energy
alright then you've got your other pair
right so we've got fifteen or side
thirty-three you're gonna kick that side
61 over the other side and go out for X
there's already approximated somewhat
this place say again
24 points Z I say 0 9 which will become
two one there's a place will become one
quick sense check does it look about
right smaller angles water slide V
growing a bigger angle bigger side
checks out
thumbs up number two again I haven't
told you what rule or school you should
use look at the information what does it
lead you towards we're going to use the
cosine rule right because I've got all
three sides okay so I need to write out
the cosine rule in its angle form cuz
that an angle is what I was okay I mean
I don't have to be bitter just be
quicker for me okay so I'm going to say
I'm gonna start with colors theta what
have on the right hand side Thanks yeah
okay so I've got let's let's get another
color here I've got these two sides
which are the sites around the angle and
then I'll put the opposite one the
opposite ones the different one isn't it
that's the C in this scheme okay so
there's my I'm going to call that a that
B and that's it right yeah okay so the
ambiguous case for sign appears when
we're worrying about angles right
because when you do sign of us us of
some thing here you will get two answers
out right but you see when I'm finding a
length aside right I never have to do
this sine inverse business okay that
never even appears I just put all these
into my calculator and out pops a single
answer and that's the only thing you
need to worry about okay so you
thankfully ready to consider that for
this right now let's come back to the
question I've got my a B and C so let's
fit them all in a squared plus B squared
minus C squared okay that's the
numerator what some might denominator to
it to a be very good to a things again
you get a number coach a little bit
let's get a before you do cos inverse
can we get a decimal for this one
another five squared plus 500 ah be
careful with your brackets what are we
gonna get at the end here should be zero
point something
yeah good what are my desperate places
can I get maybe four or five you've
already gone to the next step
no I've got oh yeah okay go ahead are
you sure yeah everyone okay something's
gone wrong
Oh hold on wait a second I think I know
haha yes I know what's going on okay
let's just pause for a second hilarious
things that happen when teachers make up
questions okay so remember I said I said
I'm expecting a zero point something now
can you tell me why you actually had
this the same knowledge that I do that
should lead you to expect the zero point
something anyone give me a suggestion
line very good I can't just draw this
over on the side here you wait we drew
the cos and sine a tan graph so you
remember that okay so it's meant to do
this and it goes up and down up and down
but it always stays between here and
here do you remember that right so the
way we said that was the range of cosine
and the range of sine as well it stays
between negative 1 and 1 okay so that's
the biggest that can possibly get and
that's the smallest it can possibly get
now all the numbers in between yeah zero
point something do you see that
like maybe 0.2 or 0.5 volt minus 0.7 etc
okay so therefore I should be expecting
a number in here like this okay so their
problem if it's a negative that just
means it's gonna be don't worry about
this part that just means it's going to
be obtuse in my second quadrant okay
uh-huh but you've given me a correctly
because of what it consistently you've
given me a one point something something
is going wrong okay because cosine can't
do that now I wonder you have a look so
I made an arrow and that's why you've
got a number which
make sensitive young there's something
fishy about this triangle we'll fix it
in a second but we might as well just
notice it before I fix it okay there's
something wrong with this something
drastically wrong this triangle can't
exists do you remember we're talking
about angles before and I said here if
you've got a right angle triangle and
the other angle you find out turns out
to be same obtuse right that's not going
to be a triangle is it like if this was
a quite worked out other than 20 degrees
here it's not going to fit inside a
triangle
my angle stops to be I have a similar
problem here that I put in by mistake
okay see how this side is 22 and I've
got two shorter sides than the 9.5 and
11.7 what happens when you add those 9.5
and 11.7 what do you get
I think you get 20 1.2 if I'm doing in
my mental arithmetic right if someone
can check that out here okay so what
that means is I've got this long side
but these two sides can't possibly be
long enough to actually meet up right
because the two shorter sides have to be
added together along in this one so my
bad okay let's fix this shall we I think
this will work if I do this that should
be okay so let's just fix up our number
there I've picked it up in two spots
okay now we should get a zero point
something can someone give me an answer
seven nine one battle dream cool fixed
okay excellent so now we've got what
cause fear is but I just want fear
itself to the nearest minute so I'm
going to use causing best yeah you can
go see if it's Klaus and that'll give
you an answer okay now what's your
calculator actually telling you after
you hit the degrees minutes seconds
button this one someone already hit it
yeah 42 degrees 142 force yeah okay so
over here you've got extra bits right
and that's the degrees minutes that'll
be seconds okay there are 60 seconds in
a minute
so am I gonna round up or down I'm gonna
run down cuz 15 is definitely in the
lower half right so I can leave it as 20
I'm done finished
okay of course if it was something else
like 731 seconds or 45 seconds or 59
seconds they would all round up and then
come 21 minutes